So let's just call the smooth guy A, because that's what we've
been doing all along. And he can either choose to cooperate, or
he can choose to defect. Now by the way, I'm saying cooperate
and defect here because they're terms of art, not because these are the
words I would have chosen. Okay? B can do the same thing.
B can choose to cooperate or B can choose to defect. Now
I've set up the game in a particular way here. The, the,
the cops have set up the game in a particular way here. If
B defects but A cooperates, then B gets to walk and A has to pay the price,
nine months in jail. So, I'm going to put into
this cell minus 9, 0. So, this means this
is the value of this set of strategies for A, and this is the value for B. So
the first number. In the pair is what A
gets and the second number's what B gets. Okay?
>> Got it.
>> You with me?
>> Yep.
>> Okay, now notice we have to do this now because it's
no longer zero sum. It's not going to always add up to a constant.
>> Oh. Well, it is, so far it's a constant negative 9.
>> That's right, oh and in fact it looks this
way as well because I have a symmetric deal here.
So if A defects and B cooperates, A gets to
walk and B goes to jail for nine months. Okay?
>> Yep.
>> So right now, you're right, it's looking like a zero sum game,
but it isn't. Because what happens if both A and B
drop a dime on each other? Well, they both confessed. So it's
a little good, it's a little bit better than having one
of them, only one of them, confess. The deal that the DA
is willing to give them is that both of them will
spend six months in jail. Now these are just, these are just,
the, the numbers that are a part of the game. This is,
I'm not computing this from anywhere. This is just the way the,
the cops have set this up. And I'm going to, now what's
an interesting question here is what happens if both A and
B keep their mouth shut? They both choose to cooperate? It
turns out that it's not a perfect world because they were
caught with a bunch of guns they didn't have permits for.
So if neither one of them admits to robbing the bank,
they're still going to do a little bit of time. But in
this case, it's a small weapon's charge and so each only spends
a month in jail.
>> I see, so now it's definitely not zero sum.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Because we have a negative 2 there, a
negative 12 there, a negative 9 and a negative 9.
>> Right.
>> Okay.
>> So, you got the game, you understand it?
>> Yeah, I think so.
>> It's very simple. Now, just looking at
this, what's the best possible outcome for the duo?
>> So if they cooperate with each other, then there's you know,
one month later, they're back on the streets, back to their criminal activities.
>> Or they're reformed. You never know.
>> Sure. Back to their choice of
whether to have criminal activities. The, the mutual
defection one, that, where they both defect,
it's either, well, 12 months or six months,
depending on how you think about it, but they don't do nearly as well. And
then the defect and cooperate, it seems like
there's a lot of incarceration that will happen.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, it feels like the best for the,
for the two of them is to mutual cooperate. Cooperate,
cooperate.
>> Yeah. And that makes sense. This is sort
of what you want to happen. Both of them
keep their mouth shut. They do a little bit
of time, but on average, they do pretty well. Right?
>> Yep.
>> So my question to you is, is that going to happen?
>> Sure, why wouldn't it happen?
>> Well, you tell me. If I know
that you're going to cooperate. Let's say that I'm
A, okay? And you're B, and I know
that you're going to cooperate. What should I do?
>> You should cooperate.
>> Should I? You've
chosen, you've chosen this column. All right?
>> I see. Well, if you think of it that way then it's not a joint choice,
but it's actually an individual choosing. Then you're
better off defecting because then you get off scot-free.
>> Yep.
>> Then, but I go to jail for nine
months. I could have a whole baby in that time.
>> Usually takes closer to ten but sure. But
you go to to jail for nine months, I don't.
>> So if you are just that cold.
I guess because you're a criminal.
>> It doesn't matter. Remember, the matrix is everything. The
value of doing this to me is 0 versus minus 1.
>> Alright, that's, that's cold, man.
>> I agree, but it's what the numbers tell
you. What if it wasn't criminal? What if it was
just, you know, the amount of money that I
was going to win in a, in a mini poker game?
>> Yeah, but it's a different kind of mini poker game,
because we're both, because. [LAUGH] It's like you beat me. But,
by beating me that way, you like, kill, nearly kill me.
>> So? Are you saying that when?
>> What do you mean so?
>> Are you saying you always let me win whenever we play poker?
>> No.
>> Okay then. Because you're cold, is that what you're saying?
>> No. Wait, what?
>> Exactly, right. So the point, Michael, is that if I know
you're going to cooperate, you're going to choose
this column, then I should defect.
>> Okay, alright, so, fine. So now I'm going to jail for nine months.
>> Mm-hm, if you choose to cooperate.
>> Aha. If, if is good. So what you're
saying is, I could drop a dime on you. [LAUGH]
>> You could. So, you could choose to defect, and if
I knew you were going to choose to defect, what would I do?
>> Well, you already, you already showed
your colors, man. You're, you're defecting, so
I'm just switching, I'm just saving myself three months by, by ratting you out.
>> Yeah, so we would end up here. By the way, you know that
this game is symmetric, right?
>> no. You defected first. [LAUGH]
>> No, here's the thing. Since the only thing I care about is maximizing my
own reward, my own value. I'm going to do the thing that makes sense for me to
do in this case which is if you cooperate, defect. If you defect, defect. But
you would do the same thing because your
whole goal here is to maximize your value.
>> Yeah, well you don't know me like that.
>> Yes I do because it's everything that's here
in the matrix. This is the wonderful thing about
game theory. All the stuff that you're concerned about is all
inside the matrix. Remember the rules of the game don't matter. There's
no prisoners here. There are no criminals. There's just, I get a
dollar, I lose a dollar, or I lose zero dollars. I lose
$9 or I lose $6. Or, for that matter, cents. I
lose one penny or I lose no pennies. I lose nine pennies
or I lose six pennies. It doesn't matter. This is the value
of these particular strategies. And I'm
going to want to defect if you cooperate.
You'll notice if you defect, I'm also going to want to defect.
In fact, if you look closely at this matrix, you
should notice something, Michael. From A's point of view, when
does it make sense for me to cooperate versus defect?
>> You mean if you have a, some
kind of probabilistic policy over cooperate and defect?
>> No, no, not even that. Just in general, is there ever a
time as A that I would rather cooperate than defect or vice versa?
>> Oh, I see. So if I know you're going to
cooperate, I should defect to, to save myself a month. But if I know you're
going to defect, I should defect to save myself
three months. Either way, I'm coming out ahead.
>> Right. So in fact, let's take a look at this.